this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
okay so
jonathan
well
i'm not going to introduce you because
anyone's that's anyone that is here is
here for you
and you also notice recently that it's
kind of silly to introduce you as a
nikon carver
i think it's hilarious i i really
actually enjoy it especially when like
jordan peterson introduces me as a
russian orthodox icon cover which is
just great it's funny
yeah and and
it is more and more visible with each
interview that you're having recently
recently that okay icon covers don't
talk about those things or
don't talk about it it's mostly that i
think it's i think it's just strange
people don't understand how to how to
frame me they don't understand what
category to place for me and then so
they struggle they have to give me a
qualifier and then they struggle to do
that right um so i think it's just part
of parcel of what i'm doing you know i'm
trying to kind of span a lot of
categories in what i'm doing so so i
think that's what that's what happens
when you try to do that
but you also studied some theology right
uh
yes i did yeah i studied theology both
uh in university and on my own i don't
have a degree or anything but i did
study in uh there's an orthodox program
here um in montreal so i studied i
studied for a few years in that program
so i have some formal some formal
theological education but most of what i
know is just from my own reading and
from my own uh
yeah
sure
but but it's not just you it's like
matthias is a very curious guy then we
recently learned about dan
how many yeah
yeah three though they're three pajo
brothers and so so yeah so material is
more
he is definitely more like a
mathematician he studied computer
science uh in school
also
yes he's more hermit like you know
that's more of his personality
and he but he him also i would say most
of his understanding and knowledge comes
from his own studies and not from the
formal uh formal world of academics we
both became very disillusioned matteo
actually
makes you actually uh quit university i
think he had like one or two classes
left before he got his degree he almost
did it on purpose because he he was so
annoyed with the academic world that he
quit just before having his degree
uh just to almost to be able to say that
he doesn't have a degree in anything so
yeah
i mean um maybe maybe it's a question to
your parents actually
not necessarily you because i i have
four little boys myself
and i wonder how to how to raise them so
that each of them like follow their own
path but at the same time is so
successful as you three are because dan
also it was like a popular guy in canada
yeah my brother
my brother dan was a professional
skateboarder at some point he was one of
the top he was like in the top seven or
ten like top ten in the world for a few
years uh just super
very technical very proficient and so
he's he's actually now a pentecostal
type pastor in vancouver and he just
opened a uh a skate park there so we're
quite like we're all the all three of us
we both we are the three of us are quite
different in some ways but then also in
other ways we're pretty we're very
similar like our father
is someone who
wasn't afraid to just blaze his his own
path like didn't feel the need to get um
the let's say the the acknowledgement of
others necessarily like it's like he
just did his thing and he did it you
know completely and so i think that we
we all three of us got that
you know we we never felt like we needed
to
have uh official titles or official
disks or official that we just did what
we did with all our all our heart really
low low inagreeableness not necessarily
to fit in oh for sure oh for sure my
tears low and agreeableness my father
too i'm higher in agreeableness
and uh and dan i'm not sure i think he's
probably pretty high and agree with this
too yeah
okay so um before we move to the
symbolic stuff i wanted to ask you about
the missionary work that you did
because i get you you say a word or two
about it here and there but we never got
like a
whole idea what what it was like and and
what what did you do there and
you were still
there right then right i know i was
orthodox
but i was
it was a it's one of those things like
don't ever do this people uh so
because what happened is i was i was
going through this crisis i would say a
general crisis which was
not
not just a crisis uh in terms of art and
there was a spiritual crisis but i was
also working a job which you know
although i
i appreciated the work and i appreciated
the job i always felt like there was
something missing or that i was
that it was just not it wasn't
particularly useful to be doing what i
was doing i was working for a project
management company
and developing uh developing uh
pedagogical material and and writing
case studies and doing animations and
doing all this stuff kind of like to
support their trainings so so that's
what i was doing i was doing that i
guess like from
1999 to 2000
1998 to 2003 maybe it's about five years
um anyways so
in that moment like i was i was just
thinking like this is not what i want to
do long term and so with my wife we had
looked at going to um to do some
volunteer work with a christian
organization um which was called mcc
mennonite central committee but i
converted to orthodoxy in 2003 and then
everything came together in 2003 to
leave and so i basically converted in
like on at pasca and left in the fall
which was just
never do that that's like the worst
thing you can do because i was basically
a new convert and i was just kind of
thrown out into the world and there in
congo where we were i was able to it
took forever i was able to finally find
a parish but it was really hard to
access it and it was difficult because
of the cultural difference you know it's
like all imagine all this cultural
difference you've just become orthodox
then you move to africa and then you go
to an
orthodox church in africa so it's really
intense and difficult but there are some
very
powerful shining moments of my time in
congo in terms of orthodoxy um
that were that were pretty powerful
anyway so while we were there what we
were doing was working with artisans
the
mcc mennonite central committee they
started a project called ten thousand
villages which is which was a series of
stores all over north america that sold
uh let's say handmade things from all
over from all over the world with with
kind of fair trade ideas like ideas of
encouraging local economies encourage
local know-how and also preserve more
traditional ways of making things
so that's who i was working with in
congo we
we basically
teamed up with a group we basically
created a network of artisans and uh
because export was so difficult to do in
congo what we did is we opened a local
store
and then used a local store to kind of
train the artisans in terms of
terms of quality in terms of design in
terms of also how to present yourself to
clients and all that because it's hard
you know when people are
are poor and are don't have a lot of
education they don't it's like they need
a bridge right to be able to
interact with people that are more
highly educated and have more means and
so we were kind of acting as that bridge
between the market and the artisans
and we did that for
four years in congo we opened the store
uh we had about working with like at
least 30 different artisans and artisan
groups
and when we so what we did is we set it
up in a way with a local partner and we
trained that person
and ultimately the last year like the
the the fourth year we we moved out of
the management of the project became
like consultants and the project just
ran for that year with the local person
and so that store remained open until
copied like it so that was like 15 years
but it was a pretty it was a pretty
powerful project especially knowing that
in
congo most projects just don't they just
don't they they they physically
yeah congo is a crazy chaotic place um
but sadly the store is in is in trouble
because of covid you know it's just they
don't have he didn't have a lot of
safety net and so i've been in contact
with our friend there his name is debo
and uh he's really struggling so we're
so hopefully like there'll be some
opportunities for him soon because it's
it's
it's tough we have at least we have
social nets that kind of help us out of
these moments but covet in africa like
in kinshasa was just
insane it's it's they had lockdowns can
you imagine lockdowns in in kinshasa
like my friend called me and he said he
said we have these lockdowns the police
are finding us we have to wear a mask
and all this stupid stuff and then he
said oh i it's like i'm just i just have
a bit of typhoid
right it's like there's diseases
everywhere in congo like people get
typhoid they give them a little bit
you don't get covered right it's like
okay as long as you don't get like
coconut is nothing compared
it was just so absurd anyways gosh so
that tells you it gives you an idea of
what we were doing and now okay so
we're using congo in three years in
kenya oh wow
was there a like a spiritual element to
it
in any way evangelization
no not at all no not in terms of the not
in terms of because i wasn't a mennonite
you know so
we didn't have official evangelization
as part of the the program it was really
more
in terms of a craft but there was always
there's there's always like a secondary
evangelization that is you know you
you
you work with people you know you you
learn from people and you become like a
testimony but to be honest
the idea of sending missionaries to
evangelize africans is the silliest
thing in the world it's like they should
be sending missionaries to evangelize us
because they're way more christian than
we are and so to me the idea of going to
africa to evangelize africans is just a
it's just not a just not something that
holds up it's it's more to to kind of
help them to give them potential to do
the projects they want to do you know so
that that's what we're doing it's
actually it's actually happening already
in poland we have a very famous ugandan
priest that goes around and gives
retreats so
you know
it's happening
but um
[Music]
in terms of
like the the orthodox church is not
necessarily known
for
sending people out into those remote
areas right
is is that this is there a reason they
will but it's different yeah it's a
different way of evangelizing orthodox
the way the orthodox will often do it is
this is that for example there was an
orthodox mission in congo which was
pretty successful uh it was more in the
interior than in kinshasa and the way
they did it is i mean they basically
send a monk a monk goes out there sets
himself up builds a hermitage you know
builds a chapel starts doing his thing
and then it attracts curiosity and
ultimately admiration and then people
start to to kind of congregate around
that monk that's that seems to be the
way that it was done also in alaska in
the different places where the uh where
the the the orthodox had a major impact
that seems it's a it's more that way
than through colonization
but that's like particularly like the
russian church or the
or the
uh yeah both the russians and the greeks
so the russians are the ones who
evangelize alaska for example and they
were very well received by the by the
local people there because of because
they didn't they didn't come with also
a lot of the colonization and the
evangelization was done with like the
military on one side
and then the evangelization on the other
and so it's very shady whereas in alaska
it was more of a just someone you know
saints who would go there and
and uh and just live with the people and
so that's what happened in congo there's
a there was i forget his name which is
horrible chicago was a greek uh it was a
greek monk who went to the interior of
congo and set up set himself up there
and um he had a massive effect i saw
some of the churches
um involved with him that's one actually
one of my little magical moments of
orthodoxy in congo is one year
one year i was in the interior when
pasca was coming around and so i was
away from my
my wife for several weeks kind of in a
small in a small area inside and kind of
in the in the congolese jungle i guess
and so
it wasn't totally in the jungle it's a
city but it's really it's more remote
and so
pascal was coming around i was i was
doing my fast for the hope for a holy
week and so i was i was like what do i
do like i won't i won't be anywhere for
pasca it's not gonna work out so i start
asking around and i start asking people
do you know about you know
you know about an orthodox church and
asking the congolese around me and a lot
of people were like i don't know what
that is and then there was one guy
who said i think i've heard of what
you're talking about this orthodox
church
and he was really fascinating because
the man he was severely handicapped he
was that he was he his legs didn't work
very well and so kind of had to drag
himself on the ground with his hands and
his feet
and um
but despite that he was like a serious
badass this guy was tough his nails i
mean a lot of the people that are
handicapped that i met in congo are
super tough they almost have to be right
because it's like they have to
overcompensate for their physical lack
so he was super tough and he's like you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna set it up
for you i'll figure it out
and so he basically sets it up he finds
he says there's a church i know where it
is he finds where the church is he sets
up his taxi to like bring me to the
church on uh on saturday in the
afternoon
so i get on this taxi the taxi breaks
down in the middle of nowhere and so we
get out of the taxi and he's with me
right so he's like there's another road
down there so we like get to the other
road and this guy's like crawling on his
hands and on his hands and legs at this
point we get to the other street he
flags down a car
and i'm not even sure it was a taxi at
this point and he's like can we pay you
to bring this guy to this place and so
anyway so i get taken to this to this
church like through this whole chaotic
thing
and i arrive
at this
church and it's like a
third
from
salinity that's like dropped in the
middle of like congolese forest it's
amazing so there's this church there and
it's saturday afternoon and i'm like
walking around and you know there are no
white people there there's no there are
no europeans there it's just it's just
called these people and so everybody's
like what is this guy doing here like
what is happening
and so i walk into the church and it has
frescoes it's beautiful
um and then people start to kind of
stream in from everywhere they kind of
just start to stream in for the for the
possible service
and i'm thinking you know it's like i i
haven't struggled i'd struggle to go to
church and i for all the holy week i was
in i was there and i'm like i need to go
to confession you know before bosca
so i'm like trying to figure it out and
i see this line forming before the
priests like okay this their people are
going to confession so i get in line
with everybody to go to confession and
it's like i come to this to this african
priest
and like i do my confession and the
whole time i'm thinking
like what is he gonna like how is he
gonna react
and he has the best reaction in the
world he looks at me after i go i
confess and he says you know
we're not pagans anymore so we really
have to live like christians and i'm
like what did i say like what is the
thing which what did i say that it's
like here's an african priest telling me
to stop being a pagan anyways just oh
you're vegan
yeah it's pretty amazing so so i was
able to commune uh that that night and
spend the night with the people and you
know it was really greek greek chanting
and everything but then when they said
christ is risen you know at the moment
of the resurrection then africa started
to like appear people started to to you
late you know when you hear women going
i started to like to be more uh
boisterous so it was wonderful so i had
so i had a few moments like that of
like amazing contact with orthodoxy in
africa wow well i certainly wouldn't
expect that to happen there
yeah well interesting you know you can't
you can't know what to expect especially
in congo everything's possible
okay
so thank you for that but let's move on
to
yeah this one is something else
okay so that
the the moment that i think i i got what
you what you meant was was
the moana video right
so where
you you brilliantly
showed that okay so we have those images
but they present this deeper reality
that tell us something about our current
situation
like like the mechanics of the of the of
the current world surface in in in that
movie and then we can see that right
and
and especially shocking was was the
scene with the the pile of those flat
stones and then the shell on on the top
right
yeah that was so clear it was i mean if
you doubt my interpretation
up to that point when you see that that
pillar with like a with a with this
shell on top it's pretty clear yeah yeah
it was it was definitely like the
the definition of of of this moment
right
yeah
but then i i checked the comment section
right in under that video and there was
someone talking about how the shell
can actually be the you know the rainbow
over the mountain or that it can be the
the crown
the crown yeah that's right yeah
that's the thing that that's what makes
it all very ambiguous and strange is
that in a way maybe that's what's
happening ultimately at this moment
but you know it does can i say this is
that that maybe that's what's happening
but it's also there's a scandalous
aspect to it it seems to happen through
scandal
but so it's like we don't excuse the
scandal even though it might be
ultimately revealing some little hint
about how all the things come together
at the end yeah
so so would that be okay to say that
so the patterns there we have we have
the pillar and we have this this let's
say the crown
but then the interpretation is something
else like if it's like a positive
finishing up of the hierarchy like the
decoration or if it's like the
i don't know the the harbinger of
breakdown soon
the thing is that in a way
so especially in moana it's
what you have in people with people in
disney and a lot of this is that they
have a very very actually profound and
intuitive understanding of these
symbolic structures but they are
weaponizing them
and so that's the problem and so
often that's what some people point out
to me they'll say like there's this this
aspect which is seems to be true or
since we pointed something true and
often they're right so for example that
image is very powerful but
in
in the story
it's represented as a kind of
replacement scheme
okay you know because it ends with
you know let's say it ends with with
maui being completely left out of the
equation and then this
you know the having moana that they
solve the problem of the goddess and all
this like it's
these two women encountering each other
ends up being the solution to the
problem and so it shortcuts the usual
masculine and feminine relationship
which caught which brings about uh
that's like the birth of a of a new
world so
so the image for example the image so
the image of the pillar is you're right
that it has there's something of it that
can actually reveal a high mystery about
reality but then it ends up being
weaponized
so you but you see that all the time
that like i said a lot of the people
even even some of the wokest the wokest
of the woke they they they have a very
deep intuition about these patterns and
they're using them
and that's why christians and
that's that's why christians and people
who don't want to be completely take
over taken over by this thing have to be
able to to understand it it's the same
with the rainbow symbols you're right
that that you know the current
ruling uh
party that that that is ruling in terms
of culture narrative they're using the
rainbow in a way that's completely
symbolically right
like it's not it's a it's a perfect
understanding of the rainbow it's just
weaponized in one direction and
therefore it becomes a problem because
yeah because it uh it is it's almost
like a devouring it's
using the ornament to devour the image
as you can imagine the idea like of the
pillar in the
and the crown it's like this crown is
trying to eat the the world it's trying
to devour the the normal yeah yeah yeah
so
like from the technical perspective when
i'm when interpreting like a work of art
like a movie or or animation of sorts
you get the full idea of what this
pillar with this shell means in in the
light of the following
scenes not not not in itself like in in
isolation right
yeah so it's you always have to
interpret the patterns as
all together like and that's i think i
always tell people when you're
interpreting a movie for example you
have to stay inside the movie as long as
possible because people tend to right
away
see something and say oh that's an image
of prometheus you know and then they
then they jump out of the movie to now
make these analogies but it's like wait
before you do that
why is that image of prometheus used
among all the other images that are
there you need to get that first before
you tell me about something else and so
i always that's my always my
recommendation is for people to let the
story
the story tell you what its
relationships are
so like if this happened again with this
happen for example in the green knight
movie where people would take certain
aspects of the green knights story
and then they would say well this is
very this is good like this is a
powerful image of
some powerful image but like okay
yeah but you have to be able to account
for all these patterns working together
in order to really see what it's about
and not just isolate one and it's the so
it ends up being the same with scripture
right ultimately with scripture
you have to kind of get to the basic
pattern
before you take a verse and you just say
and you just kind of put it out there
you know a lot of a lot of modern
christians that's what they do they just
take a verse and put it out and then it
looks like it means something but it's
you always have to have it in balance
with all the other stuff going on
okay so so you
uh teaching
all of us
the the things symbolically
the symbolic way of thinking
is a kind of apologetics right
i mean that maybe i mean i think you
could see it that way apologetics in the
sense that
it's it's at least proving let's say
proving the case that
the patterns that are in scripture are
useful for you to as a lens to see the
world and so it can open people up to to
wanting to explore them more you know
okay so do you think there is there
could be a danger in that
in
like like you had with with the green
knight like people interpreting just
things taking out taken out of context
maybe and maybe you can do the same
thing with
with the scripture right and when you
interpret oh yeah for sure
that people do it all the time with
scripture it happens all the time you
know the word heresy the word heresy
means choice
like that's what it refers to it's like
a heretic is someone who takes an aspect
of it of something
and then takes it to the exclusion of
the others
so you can you can you can use an aspect
of scripture to create complete uh you
know aberrant things like things that
aren't that are completely wrong if you
isolate them from everything else
and and symbolic thinking
does not protect us fully
from that or does it
um well it
if you truly if you do it
properly it'll help because what you
want to do is you always want to
be able to perceive the different
aspects of each part you know and so
there's also like it's there's always
especially like in old testament stories
i i always tell people you know each
character has several sides to them and
so let's say you know um
let's say jacob represents something in
in a pattern but jacob has a light side
and a dark side you can see
you can see the story from the
perspective from different perspectives
and see the effect from different
perspectives so that helps to that helps
to kind of balance things out um and so
but there there are totally have been
moments where people have pointed out to
me i think that i'm that i missed some
aspect like for example in the moana
video there are people that said well
you know maybe
you could see it this way and i'm like
oh you know what there's there's
even though i do think that that's what
disney was doing what i would like my
basic interpretation but sometimes you
can miss some aspects if you're too
focused on that well especially in the
light of all the other movies they're
making right yeah exactly it's like if
you see it if you see all these movies
getting put out with all the same thing
you know you can try to isolate one and
say this one isn't as bad but it's like
it's it's really happening in a way
that's almost impossible to i mean
if you look at what's going on now it's
just crazy like it's it's accelerating
to the levels that is just so
caricatural and absurd you know like dc
comics i think it's like almost every
one of their characters now is like some
lgbt character it's like you know wonder
woman is is is bisexual robin is
bisexual uh superman is bisexual
everybody is is one kind of
and that's just the first step because
the bisexual one is the most like the
easiest one to swallow because it it
says always selects but he's also you
know and then then it's just gonna keep
going it's gonna get weirder and crazier
and more insane
yeah recently i mean like a couple of
days ago i showed your uh
propaganda in pop culture video to my
local priest and he was like his eyes
were like
became so big and and he said oh that's
that's just peterson on steroids
what did you mean peterson on steroids
yeah because there's this saying around
our part of youtube that that
peterson is is the entry drug to pajama
right
when you notice those patterns in in in
several movies across like the across
the whole spectrum of movies then it's
like so obvious that that you just
cannot simply deny it right
um
i have a i have a question because i i
had this i had this problem recently
analyzing
waters above in in one of the animes
and
because you talked a few times about
waters above already but
i don't know because when when when the
when the mountain is is like you know
putting us in the direction to the to
putting us up like we're looking out
and then above us is also water
it's it's usually
as you say it's usually a water of
blessing
but then in that particular anime and
maybe that was just one scene or maybe
the japanese culture is somehow
disconnected from from from this way of
thinking and and it's it just doesn't
work there there were monsters as well
like the whales and there are monsters
even in western i mean you know the
story of jack and the bead stock
that the short jack and the beanstalk
has the same yeah yeah so you go up you
go up the the ladder and then you
encounter giants in the heavens
so
why right
right so the question is like we are
kind of the the hierarchy is built to to
somehow escape from the the flood that
is below or the waters below but then it
moves
upwards towards like waters as well
is this is this the way to move
well like in terms of the monsters above
you have to understand them as um you
have to understand it fract like as a
fractal
so in the same way that in the same way
that when you let's say you go into the
temple
you will encounter a cherub
at the at the door of the holy of holies
or if you're going toward eden before
you get to eden you'll encounter a
monster
at the gate of eden
so the gate of eden is higher than you
right it's already above you so there
are traditions for example that talk
about how the dog-headed men are
both like monsters from the edge of the
world but there are also guardians of
guardians of eden
so all of this is related it's the idea
that it's like if you're in a world
right so imagine you're in in any world
so the world has a lower part and the
world has a higher part right a part
that gives itself to something above now
if you move down
you'll encounter monsters you'll
encounter cerberus you'll encounter uh
you know the
the kind of tonic monsters these earth
monsters you know whatever it is that
you
the freaks the amazons all of this is at
the it's at the lower level okay um the
demons and all that stuff you see in
western imagery the demons are
underground right and they're mixtures
of all these kind of creatures but if
you go up
right you encounter angels
angels are monsters too i don't know
what to tell you they're men with wings
they they're hybrids they they but they
it's not the same it's a different it's
a you have to be careful right not to
not to um
mix them up not to confuse them because
one of them is like a guardian for a
higher level
the other one is let's say the the
that's a um you could say that it in a
way might act as a guardian for even
lower level so cerberus is a good
example yeah subaru staff people
down here from coming up
but he also acts as an image of hades
for that person that's coming this way
right so it's like if you're coming this
way you could be eaten by cerberus
cerberus is preventing these things from
coming up
so you can unders you can always
understand it that way so when you're
going up then you'll also encounter a
guardian and then that guardian will
stop you from going up
but it'll be like the lower aspect of
the higher world is the best way to
understand it okay
so you could see it as a support right
so for example so the cherub guards you
from
it's not necessarily a monster that eats
you could also use potential so like a
monster um
the cherub acts as a guardian to the
garden of eden
but the cherub is also the mount of
yahweh
right yahweh rides the cherub across the
heavens so you see that in the psalms
right so he's the potential
he's the throne
right the he he guards the throne of god
and the throne itself like the reason
why some angels are called thrones is
not arbitrary right they're the lower
aspect of what is above us
so they function in a similar way as the
throne that would be below and would
have like you know imagine a throne with
like you know uh like lion feet like you
see in a lot of these thrones like
that's that's when the throne is the
throne is potential that that that seats
your
authority
that you sit here you
establish your authority on your throne
and so it becomes an image of your
kingdom you could say
so the throne is potential and then the
crown is potential right there but it's
different it's the crown is is glory the
clown the crown is glory
but they're related they're related
together but they're not the same and
and you could say that um
you could say that metaphysically
ultimately in god they're the same but
not in the world and you have to be
careful not to confuse them because
that's you could say that that's the
trick right that's happening now one of
the trick that's happening now is to
confuse the lower waters with the higher
water
and to me try to try to change try to
kind of switch one for the other right
so you have an intuition right that
let's say the crown is the highest yeah
yeah and so so then what what the world
is trying to do now is to put the
monster up there yeah as the crown in
but the lower monster yes so that's
what's going on like it it's that's why
the the highest god right now is is you
know intersectional
monster okay so that's the flip that's
what we worship and that's the flood at
the same time because the the the the
above and the lower mix right so exactly
you could say that it's an image of the
flood because that's exactly what
happens during the flood the waters from
below come up the waters from above come
down they mix they mix together and then
the world ceases to exist okay
okay that's why a lot of this stuff is
like is is basically it's destroying the
world
it's destroying the category
and is this is this war
always going on like
do the margins always attack the center
or does the sensor always ex try to
expand to to to get the margins or do we
have a stability at times or is this
always like is this always is there
always this turmoil
i think i think that there's always a
tension but i don't think that it's
necessary to be conflict all the time so
i think that there can be um
let's say so for example like the image
of yahweh writing the cherub right so
that's an image of a
a balanced relationship between the
margin and
the higher
aspect you know you can imagine for
example uh moments where the stranger is
a wonderful um relationship of trade
with with strangers or with other
empires and you have a you have an
empire and then you have these other
empires and and they are able to have
enough peace so that the they provide
potential for each other and they
actually kind of increase the the
possibilities of each and so that's
though there are moments like that in in
history i think but it's uh it's
difficult to kind of maintain that
you know and then things tend to get
pulled a little bit on one side too much
and then they then they move to the
other and then you get this flow you
don't get the pendulum and
before you know it you have war right
right
um
as as for war um i haven't done it
during video because i was really
expecting that you would do it
i don't have a covet passport so i
haven't seen it so i'll watch it as soon
as it comes out here
in streaming i'll just get it and watch
with my family okay but but movie the
movie is one thing but you know the
story right you've read the books or
another basic story yeah basic story i
tried reading dune several times but man
i don't i really don't enjoy it and i
never finished i read like some of the
later books when i was younger but then
i tried reading the first book again
just two years ago i guess but yeah i
just didn't like i just didn't i found
the writing to be able to be too
like really heavy and and very
winded long-winded i would say yeah well
talking didn't like it either so you're
in the same yeah
i mean the the the main question i have
about about tunis is
whether it is the the return of the king
story
or the barbarians at the gates like when
when paul gets the freeman to
take over
iraqis again is this
and and i don't know how to how to
interpret that because like with each
book
with each next volume you the the story
develops and it's never finished so
yeah the consequences of that act of
that one action are spread spread across
millennia right
so you want to know if if it's the if
it's the return of the king or the
invasion of the barbarians right
that's your question
yeah
so this is gonna it's gonna not this is
not gonna be particularly uh it's gonna
be an answer that might frustrate people
is that that really depends on the point
of view right
right that's what that's this that's the
thing so think about um
that's the post think about this with
king david like king david is a great
example right so king david
associates himself with a bunch of
thieves and thugs
and like lives as an outlaw in caves you
know
and so
when he becomes king
from the point of view of king saul
yeah right
it's definitely
not great you know but for sure from the
point of view of
david then it's the arrival of the
hidden king it's the rival of the true
hidden king and so it's not it's
sometimes it story's going to have
multiple uh can be so the pattern is
true right so the pattern of the
invasion of the barbarians is true i'm
not being a postmodern and saying it's
all mush and it's all it's all uh it's
all whatever you want it to be it's like
the pattern of the return of the king or
the hidden king the secret king
manifesting himself is true the pattern
of the invasion of barbarians is true
but sometimes one can be the other
pattern from a different perspective
um and so
so but there's also like you could say
that
um you can also have things like uh
patterns of like the let's say the king
wielding old potential
like like something which was forgotten
or something which had lost you know um
so and a good example is so is is moses
leaving
egypt
right is it egypt falling into chaos
and losing control of its hierarchy
or is it the establishment of a new
identity and uh and a uh you know it's
both at the same time that's exactly
what i struggle with each time yesterday
that's great dude if you can if you're
able to perceive the patterns from the
different perspectives then you're
you're you can come very you can come a
lot closer
to insanity
no i'm not well if you're careful you
can mostly understand that
understand that let's say meaning is
everywhere right that that the
the patterns are there and in their in
their complexity and their multiplicity
and if you were able to see that in a
movie then when you go back in scripture
like i said
you'll have a much deeper understanding
of what's going on there because
you're able to see like for example
matsir was was really good at this and
and then i tried to kind of follow in
his example he would always try to say
okay so
let's read the story from the point of
view the egyptians
in the text like not not not trying to
to to to uh or for example think of a a
proverb where it says if you do this
this will happen
you know
and the the first reading is that this
is negative
but then asking yourself is there a
moment where i would want this to happen
yes right
and are there stories in the bible that
manifest that this relationship of
causality in a positive way
even though usually we think it's a
negative you know so if we once you do
that then you can then the story of
samson opens up to you and
a lot of the stories in the book of
judges that people have no idea what
they're about will kind of open up to
you
um so so so for sure it so i mean i i
would say yeah i always be careful not
to go crazy but but think that it's a
it's a good it's a good
it's a good tool to uh to to to it's a
good mental exercise to do that
it's like the stumbling stone that
destroys the hierarchies it's not
necessarily like the
the thing that that is bad but not neces
exactly so a good yeah so the example in
the the vision of daniel
right in the story of the in the vision
of daniel then you see how the the uncut
stone which comes from the mountain
crushes the feet of the of the hierarchy
and then it comes tumbling down the
description of the hierarchy is pristine
it's the best one of the best
descriptions of hierarchy that exists in
scripture is the the statue of daniel
you can apply
that hierarchy to the temple
you can actually apply the vision of the
statue of daniel which is an idolatrous
evil hierarchy you can apply it to the
way in which for example the metals are
used in the temple right it's the same
yeah but but in that case then the stone
that comes to crush it that's i mean if
you can get into that space dude you
you're
you're in a good you're in a good you're
in a good on a good road but it's uh
like you said it's hard and the hardest
part of it is communicating it
because
yeah
like if you see me in a q a hesitating
like and going i'm not sure i want to
talk about this because communicating
the different aspects and communicating
some of this subtlety and complexity is
is difficult
yeah and i mean i feel the danger of it
because i really feel that
like if i
asking myself if i'm going like too far
into into into one of those
interpretations that
that i could like i could motivate a
crazy interpretation of something
because you know i see the patterns and
it works like that like this for you and
then you know
yeah goldfish
sure you have to be careful and kind of
pull back you know and then also you
know
you could see it as um
can i say this you could you need to
have a hierarchy in interpretations as
well
you know and so
for example let's say the story has a
structure let's say the scriptural story
has a structure and has a main thrust
that is important to maintain
and then that they ornamentally or more
marginally then those those uh variant
interpretations are real and they're
possible but they're only good if you
keep them in the proper
the proper order because if you don't
then you get
very dangerous you get a very dangerous
thing right so for example like you
could say
is it possible to understand the story
of cain and abel from the perspective of
cain and the answer is of course you
can't yeah and doing that can actually
help you understand like i've i talked
about uh subtly like why christ saves
rome why christ is roman is to be able
to perceive the story from the point of
view of cain or the point of view of
esau
but that's if you if you're not careful
then you come up with
uh
people will come up with like
luciferian
interpretations of scripture because
they don't have a normal hierarchy they
they will they will flip it upside down
and you see that like a lot of the the
kind of occultist luciferian
interpretations are just them taking the
pattern flipping it upside down
and then wanting to kind of embody it
you have like an early christian sex
like you had these uh they were called
canites for example and they were they
had completely embodied the idea of the
the the let's say the upside down as
their their story you see that in um
you see that in also um
in in some of the the the weird kind of
capitalist sex like in the frankism and
and all these kind of weird late
kabbalistic sex where they they
basically said you know like we'll just
do the opposite of the law
in order to show
the totality of the patterns like dude
that's not good like that's that'll
destroy the world like that will destroy
the world uh yeah
maybe the world should be destroyed
right
yeah but what did it what did christ say
oh in christ christ has the best christ
always has the best answer to that he
says
all will be revealed you know all the
stones will be overturned
scandal must happen
but woe to those by whom it happens
right
it is the world the things so it's it's
something like uh for example
accelerationism
so people who
who want to embody accelerationist ideas
who want to bring about the end of the
world right so there are people out
there that what they want to do is they
want to bring about the end of the world
so what they're doing is they want to
accelerate the process okay so they will
embody things that they think are evil
right
they'll larp the larp as the their own
political enemy and they'll pretend to
be
super woke in order to provoke the the
the hard right in order to provoke right
and to to create more and more of this
chaos so that world so this so that this
world will end and something new will
come out of it now
like the thing is what people don't
realize is that that plays out
in you as well yeah
so it's fractally true so if you do that
for society don't think it won't affect
you
and so you will be one of those that
perishes in the flood that you're trying
to bring about yeah you're not going to
make it through
so that's why christ says things like
that where he says you know like we know
scandal must happen the antichrist must
come antichrist must appear it's all
part of the pattern understand that it's
gonna happen but that that that doesn't
mean that you should play a part in
bringing it about because it'll destroy
you
sorry man yeah yeah i think am i feeding
your insanity now like no no no no it
don't work so we know that the the
children of the revolution being eaten
etc etc it's all the same it's not the
same yeah right exactly
and and the famous line from from the
dark knight like
that some people just want to watch the
world burn and that's that's that's what
you just laid out
um
so yeah it's and and it seems um
like changing changing completely the
the the direction like with with bitcoin
again
you recently spoke to that guy
and and it's the same right it seems
that two patterns are
or the two phases of the same pattern
around are going on there like
bitcoin is supposed to topple the the
central banks right
but are the central banks the the proper
hierarchy or are they the corrupt
hierarchy and bitcoin has this is this
people that keep using that immaculate
conception of bitcoin like it's
the savior of the monetary system or
something and how to interpret the
bitcoin is it is it you know one or the
other or is it both and and
yeah you never know
no but the thing
how can i say this
so the for example like let's say the
the the decentralized idea right the
idea of the decentralized blockchain and
to create a completely decentralized uh
network that is almost automatic because
it doesn't have a hierarchy yeah it's
like
those things don't exist in a vacuum
like something like that will call to
more control and more it was the same
with you saw you saw it happen in the
internet right the like the internet it
was like oh this great thing where now
the sudden everything is available and
everybody can just say whatever they
want and everybody can be anonymous and
do whatever they want and people thought
like it was it was basically a
manifestation of like the of a kind of
anarchic freedom and it was for a while
right yeah
but now look at it
right right because because extremes
call upon each other right and extremes
call call to each other and so the idea
that bitcoin will just be left to exist
and that
that's why if you watch my conversation
with uh actually i think it's not out
yet i did a conversation with robert
reid love
that's going to be on his on his podcast
i think okay and um and i kept bringing
it back to like guns and weapons and
saying you know in the end you know it's
like this will play out
the power of of like the mechanical uh
state that has weapons
is going to play itself out in terms of
you think bitcoin is not just going to
remain online if bitcoin becomes a
threat to the system it's going to play
itself out in the streets with with real
dangerous weapons it's not going to
continue to just be online that's
a silly idea to think that that's how
it's going to play out anyways i think
it's naive
yeah it's going to call for more control
if people want to defend bitcoin they
will eventually have to do it in the
streets right
i mean i don't know how it's going to
happen but i'm just saying that it's not
it's not it's not a it's not a simple uh
it's not a simple just
it's not simple to think that it's just
going to take down the central bank like
i don't and like i said it's like the
idea that that
bitcoin is secret power
is not necessarily something that you
want either
okay
like do you like
it's gonna reveal all these so basically
you have you you have right now possibly
massive billionaires and bitcoin keeps
going up maybe you'll have trillionaires
right bitcoin trillionaires who are
their only
reason why they're trillionaires is
because they own this coin that's the
only reason they've never built anything
they've never done anything they're they
don't they they've never managed people
they don't they're just people who
bought this coin
and so is is that who you want to rule
you like i'm not saying the people that
are ruling us now are doing a great job
it's horrible and there's a lot of
horrible stuff going on but it's like am
i going to trade that
for a bunch of guys that bought bitcoin
in 2011
really
no thank you like seriously no thank you
i
i think i think there is there is some
evolution in in your ideas about
governance
correct me if i'm wrong because i
remember you telling us um
three four years ago maybe about
obedience to
to the authority right and you still
keep that
but we as when when kovit came like you
had you had expanded this
if you want
yeah
super super obedient so my if you want
to know my position now is that
sometimes you have to disobey and you
disobey and you accept the consequences
that's the way that i see the saints do
it it's like if you look at the way that
um
let's say someone like sam maximus the
confessor for example he just said
you're wrong he said he told the emperor
you're wrong emperor
you've got it wrong and everybody's like
if you keep saying i'm wrong i'm gonna
i'm gonna hurt you and he's like you're
wrong
and so he cuts his hand off okay and
then sam actually says you're wrong
and the number says if you keep saying
i'm wrong i'm gonna hurt you so he cuts
his tongue
out and then say maximus gets sent into
exile
and it's like
i'm not saying that that's easy but i'm
saying that
so say maximus never said never tried to
get an army
never tried to raise an army to fight
the emperor like another
like another character in the middle
ages who who disagreed with uh with his
his hierarchy let's say
so you can see the difference between a
revolutionary
and someone who disagrees for the sake
of the of the the world itself
you know
that's what i think but i mean
i don't know when things hit the fan
like who knows what's gonna how it's
gonna it's gonna play out because it's
it's not getting better that's for sure
that's for sure yeah
well on this positive now
[Laughter]
i want to thank you very much for coming
to my channel especially in the in this
time when it's like
it seems that you have an interview
every day somewhere and
you're becoming very popular very
quickly especially with god's dog and
and everything that is going around it
that you're fine well thanks for the i
really love your interpretations and i
feel like i remember the the first time
i saw them was actually my two of them
sent me your video yeah i don't know how
he had stumbled upon it
and uh yeah how did it happen
yeah and so we both we both really we
really saw that you have a very uh very
strong symbolic intuition and so
if you cannot go crazy
like i think it'll i think it'll serve
us all well
well i'll try i'll try i tried to carve
out the niche with that anime and
symbolism but it seems that this this
niche can be non-existent almost because
like there aren't many people interested
in both things at the same time
yeah but i mean i would say just i would
say to keep doing what you're doing
again to to to uh to do it the best you
can and uh
i mean it sure also
the the the fact that a lot of your
videos are in polish is is obviously
limiting to
their reach let's say so that's
definitely going to to happen but you
know i for sure the ones that i saw in
english were really really excellent so
yeah keep going
yeah so thank you very much and i invite
everyone to go
and buy
and support
god's dog and i hope that this develops
into like a multi-book series and then
who knows what
thanks jacqueline i really appreciate it
it's good to meet you in person finally
thank you jonathan see you have a nice
day as you know the symbolic world is
not just a bunch of videos on youtube we
are also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support